premières élections municipales le débat
[Musique]
bonsoir chères auditrices et auditeurs
et internautes qui nous suivaient en
direct en ce moment sur martinique la
première et vous pourrez également
retrouver cette émission de débat
municipal en podcast dans tout dans les
toutes prochaines heures sur notre site
web
un débat consacré ce soir à la ville de
basse pointe et que j'ai le plaisir de
présenter et d'animer avec un niveau riz
bonjour alain bonsoir bonsoir à nos
invités bonsoir aux auditeurs ou youtube
heures et internautes
voilà bonsoir plutôt que bonjour
effectivement à cette heure là vous avez
raison et avec quatre candidats têtes de
liste en place
marie thérèse casimir youth la maire
sortante bonsoir madame nous sommes 6
cadrés et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation tout comme madame edith vela
nous donnons soir lens pharmaciens
caruge et merci pour l'invitation
également avec nous dit diego levée
bonsoir bienvenue et lucien césarine
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur et merci
également à vous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour participer à ce débat
nous commençons alain livory par une
présentation succincte de cette ville de
bath points alors basse pointe en un
clin d'oeil au 1er janvier 2020 c'est
environ 3000 26 habitants contre 3700
habitants en 2010 la paroisse a été
écrit en 1663 c'est l'une des plus
anciennes de l'île avec st pier richer
car bécasse pilote et le marin
basse-pointe a été érigée en commune en
1837 la fête patronale de base soit je
me trompe c'est le 24 juin
certes leurs superficies 2795 actares il
y à quelques personnalités célèbres à
basse-pointe indécise hier le professeur
renaud gare saint hippolyte le dr
hippolyte mot resta et françois charles
pécoul merci alain après cette
présentation de la commune
on va demander aux candidats de se
présenter succinctement aussi en moins
d'une minute si c'est possible
une minute maximum
nous commençons avec vous monsieur
lucien césarine le dit bonsoir à tous
les points 3 les points 3 et à tous les
auditeurs qui compte deux parties une
première
je suis monsieur césar et lucien je suis
d'origine de basse-pointe nea quartiers
qu'ailleurs basse - j'ai une proposition
je suis chef d'exploitation agricole oui
et qui fait que voilà un jeu s'ils
naviguent un petit peu en métropole
pendant une quinzaine d'années et je
suis revenu sur la martinique ça fait 16
ans et qui fait que je fais
nos vies de savoir pourquoi vous
présentez alors les grands manèges
pourquoi je veux me présenter je me
présentais pense que quelque part j'ai
connu mon quartier je suis né avant ce
point j'ai grandi à basse-pointe
apprécié xi albert sven systématiquement
j'ai vu l'évolution de basse pointe et
j'ai vu aussi la régression de basse
pointe en tant que point 3 je me suis
dit il faut que je compte monter à
l'édifice de façon apporter mon savoir
méconnaissance mes expériences
personnelles et professionnelles enfin
que les points 3.3 puisse en décider de
l'opportunité que leur offre pour
choisir prochainement le maire tout
c'est à votre tour marie thérèse casimir
youth de vous présenter bonsoir à tous
mais si vous le permettez je voudrais
déjà à d'emblée présenté des voeux au
point 3 0 pour toi qui nous écoutent
marasme des martiniquais début d'abord
de très bonne santé
je sais que des poèmes de la santé
actuellement mais surtout on a un peu
plus loin de voeux de réconciliation
démenti nickel avec eux mêmes d'abord et
dans un souci d'unité je crois que nous
sommes une terre de résistance y est
mais nous sommes surtout une terre dans
le nord attachés à des valeurs des
valeurs de respect et des valeurs
surtout d'apaisement pour faire unique
et même dans une diversité aussi plus
est soit elle
alors on vous connaît tellement que
finalement c'est un peu inutile vous
présenter marie thérèse casimir yeux
reconnaître quand je ne pense pas que ce
soit à y ait beaucoup de tirer en ce qui
me concerne mais je crois que je me
définis comme une femme de convictions
et non une femme d'ambition très attaché
à des valeurs de gauche très attachés
notamment à ce concept d'égalité pour
tous partout devant tous et au respect
de l'être humain et c'est ce qui fait
que je suis très attaché à ce que
j'appelle à proximité avec les uns et
les autres
edit vela bidon c'est à votre tour
présentez vous alors je me présente à
mais je suis originaire de la commune de
basse pointe
j'ai effectivement comme beaucoup de
jeunes de
de mon époque nous sommes partis donc
j'ai fait dix années
en guyane 4 en guadeloupe 8 dans les
hauts-de-seine avant mais je suis revenu
à la martinique il ya une dizaine
d'années je suis mère de famille de deux
grands enfants 29 et 28 ans j'exerce
dans l'éducation nationale
et puis pourquoi je me présente à
basse-pointe ce nom
n'est pas je veux dire un objectif
récent ça a toujours été quelques chose
que je vois là que je sais c'est
l'occasion aujourd'hui mais m'est
offerte
tout simplement parce que les questions
de carrière de famille voilà ce que les
femmes ne sont pas dispensés un des
responsabilités familiales et donc
aujourd'hui je pense que j'ai là le
temps et l'énergie pour pouvoir me
positionner en tant que candidate ceci
étant dit je saisis cette occasion pour
souhaiter des meilleurs voeux à tous les
auditeurs et auditrices de la martinique
est aussi au point 3 c'est vrai c'est la
santé ça la santé en est rien
mais c'est surtout aussi à la sérénité
et la fraternité je crois que sans ça on
peut pas avancer aujourd'hui à notre
époque
quand on regarde l'actualité souvent
cédé des rapports de force entre
personnes qui font et qui freine tout le
débat à la fois politique et toute la
construction qu'on peut faire pour le
monde meilleur voilà et puis c'est au
tour donc de didier goux levée de
terminer de conclure cette séquence de
deux présentations d'auto présentation
même des candidats en lice pour
l'élection municipale et communautaire
de basse-pointe raison soir un enjeu
aussi je présente aussi mes voeux à tous
les auditeurs plus particules
particulièrement aux pointes oiseaux
pointois a lancé golvet dj moi j'ai
jamais été dans une basse pointe je suis
toujours resté j'ai fait 41 ans que je
suis à basse-pointe j'ai aujourd'hui je
me présente parce que les points toiser
les pointois sont en grande souffrance 1
comme je les ai répété à maintes
reprises j'ai fait partie d'une équipe
en 2014
j'ai même été suppliant de la maire
sortante en 2008 sur les cantonales
aujourd'hui qui nous a profondément déçu
par pas que moi
la majorité des pointes au des pointes
allant des mois vous aurez le temps de
m'expliquer ça d'expliciter même oui on
vous demande de vous présenter alors
j'ai dit je suis technicien au service
des eaux et je suis natif de basse
pointe et je suis du quartier de dément
ça fait longtemps que vous êtes un
militant politique que vous êtes engagés
plus démunis scène depuis 2007
oui merci didier golvet nous passons
donc à une autre séquence nous vous
retrouvons alain à propos d'un
micro-trottoir maintenant alors
effectivement ans bertrand nous sommes
rendus à basse-pointe sous les pointes
roanne nous ont livré leur vision de ces
élections
ce qu'ils attendent du scrutin de 2020
la continuité du travail est commencé
l'entente la population les travaux les
avancées voilà c'est tout piège allemand
au point de vue travailler puis se
guérir de la room vous êtes satisfait de
la commune telle que vous la voyez
aujourd'hui
pas tout à fait il ya des choses à faire
c'est plutôt pour les emplois pour les
jeunes
et puis quand la commune ce vaio
l'histoire pour que l'échangé se charge
pas pour avoir les meilleures choses
pour les jeunes surtout pour les jeunes
qui viennent à ce moment les jeunes
puissent s'intégrer à l'est des loisirs
de tous c'est un cermak mais c'est pas
encore vraiment ça ouais ça va ça va
démarrer mais pas beaucoup la nature la
jeunesse au point en compte les jeunes
leur donner un objectif et le tourisme
historique vient ici pour voir autre
chose ça nous va aller devant les
soignants lobaye par clairvaux mineurs à
l'annuler et moonan qu'il a il j'ai eu
les choses qu'on gagne
marie thérèse casimir yeux cela n'a pas
vocation de sondages mais qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce micro trottoir les
points 3 à disent qu'ils veulent du
changement et ils veulent aussi des
actions en faveur des jeunes je pense
que si tout à fait normal qu'elle les
parce que vous avez ça dépend de là où
se trouve
et moi je suis quelqu'un de réaliste
suivrait jeudi entre le rêve et la
réalité c'est vrai qu'à une marge mais
je crois qu'il ya nous avons toujours
voulu être très visible par rapport à
des actions vis-à-vis des jeunes mais
monsieur livory on ne peut pas nous
demander de faire en cinq ans ce qui n'a
pas été fait en dix neuf ans d'une part
et je crois que si vous je vous parle
d'un indicateur je pense que faire quoi
aux jeunes on parle d'emploi des jeunes
que la commune de basket peut les
pousser en bouche et ce n'est pas faire
preuve d'honnêteté et de responsabilité
mais par un autre biais par le biais de
la mission locale je peux vous dire
qu'en cinq ans ce sont 210
neuf jeunes clients étaient recrutés à
qui la mission locale a proposé à ma
demande parce que nous sommes dans le
cadre de la loi nôtre il faut donc
utiliser les outils se sont aussi quatre
jeunes qui ont bénéficié d'un poids
saisonniers encore d'ici par la mission
locale et nous avions au départ
embaucher 25 jeunes en contrat aidé et
je pars faire il faudrait s'il nous
n'avons pas pu continuer au niveau des
emplois aidés c'est vous connaissez bien
la raison c'est que ça a été supprimée
par des administrations gouvernementales
donc jamais moi je pense que c'est
vraiment un faux problème de faire
croire aux jeunes que la la collectivité
l'amérique peut tous les ans boucher
michel six arènes qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce micro trottoir que vous
avez entendu les seconds saison que nous
avons interrogés parlent beaucoup de
changements alors je pense aussi par le
changement c'est parce qu'ils sont pas
satisfaits de ce qui se passe au niveau
de la commune de base parce que je pense
soit 70 points noirs aux interviews et
c'est un trois là ils ont retourné sur
la commune et qui fait que à ce moment
ils ont grandi ils ont fait leurs
activités etc mais ils ont vu passer les
maires et ils ont vu madame qu'asus à
l'oeuvre dans la commune
on va réaliser les et continuer et qui
fait à ce moment là je pense ils disent
telle chose c'est parce que ils sont
moins contents ils sont mécontents parce
que ya pas de résultats nous voulons et
constatent comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
que la commune en train de régresser
énormément lorsque je me rappelle autant
de monsieur jouhaud hnt 4500 habitants
et on trouve on est arrivé à à 3026
habitants qui veut dire quelque part on
se passer des autres habitants s'il ya
quelque chose de positif qui se passait
sous basse pointe etc
je pense qu'on nous regarde et on va on
va évoquer une baisse de population mais
ces défauts reprendre un petit peu le
micro temps pour moi parce que ça nous
convient pas
voilà madame vela ludon pour toujours
faire le tour de table sur la réaction
suite au micro trottoir votre votre avis
alors moi je pense que d'abord une
municipalité n'a pas pour vocation de
faire que de l' embauche d'accord une
municipalité c'est d'abord une dynamique
qu elle impulse dans sur le plan
associatif sur sa gestion sur des
infrastructures qu'elle met en place la
création d'emplois dans le secteur
alors c'est peut-être un thème de
campagne que j'avais aux sénatoriales
je crois qu'il faut développer le tissu
économique
alors c'est un bien grand mot surtout
quand on est dans une région il ya un
désert médical vous avez effectivement
et une diminution de population
la diminution de population et les
paliers parce que il y a eu telle
politique menée à 19 ans ou sélective et
depuis pardon 2014
tout simplement parce que vous avez une
réalité économique est à la fois
mondiale et nationale
et puis aussi vous avez des aspirations
de la part des jeunes qui sont des fois
d'être plus dans une grande ville
connaître dans une vie libre dans une
dans une commune ça c'est la première
chose pour rendre bas soit attractif et
souvenirs aussi
il faudrait qu'il y ait de l'emploi pour
pouvoir permettre à tout le monde de
pouvoir trouver à mieux vivre
monsieur monsieur golvet sûr c'est sur
ce micro trottoir ce qu'on a nous avons
interrogés disent qu'il faut un
changement et qu'il faut des actions en
faveur des jeunes des vous ont pensé
quoi bien tout est bien le changement
j'avais dix ans vous avez entendu le
changement donc qu'est-ce que ça
signifie pour vous quand sandra sassine
il a envie de changement ça veut dire
que ça ne bouge pas dans la commune mais
mais pas du tout cette interprétation
que vous en faites n'est pas du tout ça
ne bouge pas du tout la commune de
batman c'est bien pour ça aujourd'hui
qui a quatre candidats c'est bien
aujourd'hui bien bon ça aujourd'hui qu'à
trois candidats face au maire sortant
aujourd'hui de ce lieu c'est beaucoup
mais ça n'a jamais été à basse-pointe
c'est qu'ils aient un réel souci
aujourd'hui le maire sans t'en parle de
rêve
les jeunes ne rêvent pas tout
travail à la collectivité il rêve juste
d'avoir une vie meilleure et de
travailler tout simplement
peu importe pas obligatoirement à la
collectivité c'est un mensonge aussi de
faire croire que tout le monde du
travail la collectivité ce n'est pas
vrai le centre culturel de gr 10 en 2014
pourquoi on en parle de ceux qui ont des
projets a appelé le serval cermak curie
pourquoi on en parle de basse pointe
parce qu on a fait plein de promesses
aux pointes oiseaux pointois en 2014 sur
le centre culturel le gr 10 voilà
pourquoi aujourd'hui le mécontentement
des pointoise et des points toi et voilà
pourquoi en mars
on aura le changement tant escompté par
là pour la population eh bien nous
allons maintenant jeter un coup d'oeil
dans le rétroviseur si vous voulez bien
donc on va jeter un oeil sur la
mandature qui va s'achever donc une
mandature sous la houlette de marie
thérèse casimir youth mandature madame
la maire qui a été agitée à madame la
maire sortante avec alors faut-il le
rappeler des démissions en cascade je
sais pas mais il y en a eu plusieurs
démissions de conseillers municipaux
jusqu'à en arriver donc à une élection
partielle il ya un peu moins d'un an
c'était en mars donc 2019
du coup marie thérèse casimir yeux c'est
ce que vous considérez que cette
situation pourrait constituer un
handicap pour vous ou est ce que vous
vous êtes bien remise depuis cet épisode
de l'élection municipale partielle d'il
ya un an
alors monsieur k oui j'ai pour habitude
de dire que les épreuves
quelle que soit la la la le chemin
donnez lui n'est jamais très facile et
que par conséquent ces simples contribue
à donner beaucoup plus de 2 de maturité
et d'expérience maintenant c'est vrai on
a beaucoup c'est parce que les médias
ont beaucoup parlé de basse pointe des
démissions je veux simplement rappeler
que des démissions au sein du conseil
municipal c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment très basique un peu partout qui
se passe partout on le voit aussi au
niveau du gouvernement qui a un débit
nice qui démissionne mais je ne sais pas
pour quelle raison on a voulu en faire
tout un vraiment un fromage une série
une série de
oui c'est mais au gouvernement aussi
gouvernement de monsieur emmanuel macron
vous avez beaucoup de de démission mais
bon je ne vais pas épiloguer sur ce
point là mais enfin je crois que ça ça
nous appellent au niveau de la
constitution
les élus au niveau de la possession
d'une équipe à bas à prendre cette anam
d'assurance et d'être vraiment sûr nous
sommes dans un objectif partagé c'est à
dire toujours faire la différence entre
des objectifs personnels de réalisation
de soi et de l'autre côté je sais celles
et ceux qui veulent général alors est ce
que vous allez constituer votre liste
différemment parce que c'est ça veut
dire quoi vous allez chercher choisir
quel type de critères parce que on vous
pensait proche de vos colistiers on a vu
une démission en cascade
comment elle fait à votre choix alors il
ya un certain nombre de critères
évidemment déjà de partage de ces
données de valeurs de partage d'un idéal
et surtout surtout que nous soyons bien
devant lorsque je parle d'une vision
partagée que nous soyons vraiment dans
l'optique nos objectifs de servir une
population et pas d'en intégrer
personnels égoïstes
je crois que c'est d'abord où ça et puis
se basait aussi sur un certain nombre
d'heures a alors nous avons tous
tendance à passer à nous baser sur des
compétences supposées dans une banque
d'un métier dans le domaine d'expertisé
et pas dans les compétences vérifier de
gestion et puis surtout je parlais tout
à l'heure de proximité d'intégrer pour
la proximité en quelques mois l'algérie
va poser une question a dit diego levée
qui était votre conseiller municipal en
votre majorité au début mais marie
thérèse casimir yeux c'est ce que vous
vous même à titre personnel cet épisode
vous a fait changer évoluer changer de
méthodes de management parce que on a
entendu dire à basse-pointe que
tout cela était dû aussi à une certaine
forme de à l'est pour aller vite de
mauvais caractère
on va dire ça comme ça comme si vous
êtes avec vos explications
on a beau parler de dictature alors bon
moi je vous même vous dire vous dire que
l'un dictateur c'est quelqu'un lorsqu'il
existe des lois et des règles qui
décident de passer outre
lorsque un conseil municipal prend une
décision
je vous dis quelque chose de basique et
qu'on décide de passer outre
ça c'est de la dictature mais il faut
savoir que conformément au code des
collectivités territoriales le maire est
garant du respect et du suivi des
décisions prises par le conseil
municipal et que par conséquent il faut
on a trop souvent tendance à dieu ah oui
parce que c'est un tel il faut laisser
passer il faut dit si vous voulez
seulement lorsqu'il y aura un rappel à
l'ordre du conseil de la légalité ce
n'est pas allé lui c'est le maire
reconnaît donc par conséquent moi j'ai
toujours respecter fidèlement cette
mission d'être garante du respect des
règles et des procédures
alors monsieur golvet qu'est ce qui vous
a gêné dans cette mandature parce que
vous étiez à aux côtés de marie thérèse
camériste vous avez démissionné visited
ans donc dans le camp du maire sortant
pourquoi qu'est ce qui vous a gêné alors
tout d'abord vous savez comment on
banalise les démissions en cascade et
ces personnes là ont été choisis par le
maire sortant
toutes les personnes qui ont démissionné
il faut fut bien faire comprendre à la
population au point 3 au printemps que
ces personnes là ont été choisis bas par
le maire sortant
c'est pas qu'on lui ait posé des
personnes moi je suis là depuis 2007
j'ai été son suppléant sur les
cantonales gelé défendu bec et ongles
même après le mandat du 2014 j'ai fait
partie j'étais pas ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu est-ce qu
est-ce qui vous a gêné ce qu'imaginait
on 1,40 et toutes les personnes
aujourd'hui qui faisait de l'ombre ou
bien qui qui avait qui disait qui
arrivait à entrer en opposition avec
marie thérèse casimir y aussi folle d
le maire sortant il faut laisser
personne les aéroports pas la
contradiction marica c'est sérieux c'est
ce que vous voulez dire où tu lâches et
sa station
c'est tout à fait ça aujourd'hui et
c'est tout à fait ça aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui toutes les décisions qui
sont prises à la mairie sont prises pas
un sit-in monarchie c'est une c'était
c'est une petite un petit noyau de
personnes aujourd'hui qu'ils prennent
des décisions dont le maire sortant donc
là il me rater est ce qui vous a poussé
donc oui les traiter votre démission
tout à fait bien plus il ya d'autres
choses aussi
on a parlé on peut parler aussi du dst
du dst gérer des services techniques
exactement aujourd'hui a été quoi
qu'est-ce qui est ce monsieur on fait
comprendre à la population de
basse-pointe ont fait comprendre la
frustration que ce monsieur un directeur
des services techniques a volé un
portable on fait comme un téléphone on
fait croire qu'il a volé un téléphone
portable on fait quoi qu'il n'est pas
compétent
on fait croire qu'ils aient ce même
monsieur et on a été le chercher en
guyane on a glorifié ce monsieur
effectivement j'ai travaillé avec lui un
monsieur très compétent aujourd'hui la
preuve qui travaille dans une ville
voisine de loin c'est qui les lie les
compétences c'est qu'il est compétent
aujourd'hui ce monsieur qui n'est pas
compétent par certains j'ai travaillé au
domicile du maire sortant travailler au
domicile du maire sortant aujourd'hui il
ya plein d'affaires on a le maire
sortant était entendue et et à la
gendarmerie ça fait deux semaines
elle était entendue je sais pas si on
n'a pas les tenants et les aboutissants
d'où la maison était bien aujourd'hui on
fait croire que vous le voudrez
j'ai moment avoir un entretien de
enregistré de sa de cette affirmation
j'ai été convoqué d'après vous qu'est
attendu cet enregistrement podcasts ou
non aujourd'hui fait croire que ce bout
de ces jeunes filles vous allez pouvoir
répondre va pouvoir répondre à ce point
et toi alors soudain conclure oui ce
point toi on l'a critiqué on la salle et
ce jeune homme on la rabaisser plus plus
bas que terre
pourquoi on ne sait pas donc ce sont les
motifs de votre dimension supportiez
plus avant alors des motifs mais des
motifs madame madame v laâyoune dont je
veux savoir comment vous voyez tout ce
contexte parce que vous avez été
candidat sur la liste de mariage lors de
l'élection à l'élection partielle
non vous voyez tout ce contexte on sens
bien qu'ils aient une grosse tension qui
règne à abbas alors d'abord j'ai été
aussi sur la liste d'andré charpentier
l'un 2014 et ensuite sur celle de
patrick et marie laure c'était une liste
de rassemblement il y avait à la fois
des démissionnaires de l'équipe de
madame casimir yeux c'est a eu des
nouvelles personnes qui n'ont jamais eu
à s'intéresser aux affaires citoyenne de
la ville et puis il ya eu ce qui était
aussi qui avaient déjà une expérience
politique
comment je vois tout ça
je n'ai pas la même autant de détails
sur ce qui se passe à l'interné au
niveau du conseil municipal parce que je
ne gère pas toutes les manières quand il
y a des difficultés il ya forcément
forcément des difficultés au niveau de
la gestion des ressources humaines
voilà pour ce qu'il y ait de toutes ces
démissions même si il y en a environ au
gouvernement même s'il peut y en avoir
dans d'autres lieux
c'est quand même assez comment dirais-je
flagrante pour la ville de basse pointe
je pense que sous la vème république à
un an des élections on n'a pas avoir
souvent une élection partielle qui est à
la fois ont reconduites ceci étant dit
magazine russe a renforcé son essai
puisqu'elle a remporté brillamment cette
élection donc je pense qu'il faut
regarder les choses avec aussi lucidity
maintenant je pense qu'aujourd'hui sur
basmati faut de la besvre il faudra
l'apaisement parce qu on est beaucoup
dans des conflits de personnes et ça ne
peut pas continuer vous ne pouvez pas
avancé pour plusieurs raisons parce que
c'est une petite commune
tout le monde avait souhaité famille et
donc moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça ne
peut pas continuer quelle que soit
l'équipe qui va arriver en tête
le 15 mars seulement 15 minutes sur le
monsieur gaulle vie la mienne cela
faisait dix on doit ramener la paix à
bassoues et ça ne peut plus continuer
parce que beaucoup de defra structures
ont été démolies avec une année sport de
reconstruction qu'il n'est pas
reconstruit et on se retrouve au joug du
salé même plus dans du changement ce
qu'on avait crié en 2014 du changement
du changement que la population a eu en
2020 ses preuves c'est plus du
changement lassé de la reconstruction
vous avez un tas de bâtiments qui est
démolie vous avez des personnes qui sont
parties qui ont quitté la commune a eu
l'idée ça ait eu des gens qui sont
partis pour des raisons professionnelles
mais vous avez des personnes qui sont
aller habiter avec dans les communes
avoisinantes
alors il donc ça aussi c'est aussi une
catastrophe at il commet non là on n'a
pas signé spatiale un livre il avait
signalé il ya une particularité
basse-pointe c'est qu'il ya plus d ce
cri que d'habitants donc il ya des
personnes qui ont quitté la commune mais
qui équivaut cette marotte toujours
c'est un film on finit le tour de table
avant de vous donner la parole madame
casimir y eut ce monsieur cesari comment
vous voyez toute cette ambiance autour
des élections
moi je dis c'est un petit peu dommage
pourquoi ce jeudi c'est un peu dommage
parce qu fin de compte on est une grande
famille a besoin c'est donc que
lorsqu'on regarde autant boudon à kayes
et d'accueillir dimanche on a toujours
rien familial et qui fait
systématiquement je trouve ça un peu
dommage que la ville de basse pointe est
arrivé à ce point là non mais des fois
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
non bien sûr oui pardon divergent oui
toujours avoir hésité parce que je
développement de sociétés les jolies pas
toujours d'accord mais c'est un doux
quelque part il y avait un tissu quelque
part qui me tenait un petit peu les
points soit 10.3 et qui fait
systématiquement tout ce tissu est parti
à plus de liens se nouent peu pantois au
niveau sportif sur ma page j'étais
joueur de l'étoile de basse-pointe bien
j'ai tout à fait 150 à 200 jeunes je
faisais partie de ces jeunes a
pratiquement on a plus ça c'est pour
montrer au niveau associatif et cetera
s'il n'y en a plus a systématiquement la
commune décret alors mal thérèse casimir
y est vous avez été mise en cause par
diego levée
notamment sur le directeur des services
techniques mais aussi sur ses jeunes
qu'est ce que vous avez à répondre alors
concernant le dcg la vie dit le
procureur donne une notification de
rappel solennelle adducteurs du fait que
son comportement constitue une
infraction punie par la loi
cet investissement est effectué par le
2-1 de rien je n'ai alors je trouve
aussi qu'il n'y avait pas de fumée sans
feu kouassi le jir d'hier le travail à
2006 je crois pas dans dans ce cadre là
tout le monde peut émettre un certain
nombre de suggestions
en fait moi je reste à ma place il y a
les services de l'état mme qui font leur
travail pour que la bri au travail et je
pense que s'il m'a fait cette réponse
c'est parce que c'est de cesser de sa
mission ce n'est pas ce débat de la
mienne deux points de lyon
maintenant j'ai entendu parler
d'apaisement par man en ville elle dort
je vais lui sortir ça se soit ce sont
les points 3 qui sortent des éléments
des archives des pratiques a été
effectuée par la droite à l'époque hamas
- et qui a créé un tel désarroi au
niveau de la ddt de la population par
des méthodes de pression et que je ne
peux pas desserré je reviens jusqu'où
aller entre les bonnes et c'est une
méthode est pendante pendant la
caricature ses factures pendant l'appel
de 2010 de fin mars 2010neuf on a nous
dynamique point casse a circulé pendant
l'élection et la campagne de l'élection
parti avait la même méthode les mêmes
pratiques
alors qu'on ne vienne pas aujourd'hui me
donner des leçons sur l'apaisement je
crois que bien au contraire nous avons
tout fait et elle est ce document date
devant ce qu'ils disent mais vous savez
ça sur des points 3 qui ont archivé ces
documents et qui me fait un faux pas
revenue ces documents ça fait longtemps
ça ça fait très longtemps et on se rend
compte que ça continue et que vous
voulez l'avion
les neuf sages à la main sap a circulé
service de musique à 10.3 les anciennes
ont remis ça en disant que c'était
inadmissible qui se faisait avant alors
j'en mets à manses 2019 au site monsieur
mais c'est un juge
nous avons des caricatures des
publications d'ailleurs là aussi un il
ya un dossier en béton ou au mieux pour
que de la république pour de la
diffamation ou c'est la même méthode
mêmes pratiques des caricatures des
jeunes avaient réellement d'avoir 2
alors moi je veux pas qu'on dise qu'on
vient de me donner des leçons
d'apaisement parce qu'il ya un certain
climat si on veut la sérénité lorsque
j'entends parler de sérénité je crois
que nous sommes c'est cela qu'il faut
entrer dans la construction la
coresponsabilité nous sommes tous
responsables il faut pa kone qu'on soit
à un conte deviennent subitement sénile
en ou bien cette a été fait dans le bas
cible et qu'on ne me fasse pas c'est un
lieu de pouvoir me fait apporter le
poème de l'apaisement il y avait
effectivement une profession vous avez
vous beaucoup d' avance et tout cela va
nous permettent pas de parler de ce chat
la droite a fait subir à ma mère
le le parti que soutient alain verdeaux
qu'on me fasse pas parler à la fois de
la mer mais aussi d'autres personnes
entendues en disant on va parler m
d'être actives âgées de la commune
populations locales quelle solution
quelle solution car dix ans la
deviennent obèses tentative a donc perdu
la commune de basse prades a donc perdu
en dix ans 6 185 habitants
c'est génial capital hausse les
habitants c'est celle de ducos oui c'est
vrai la note mais celle de basket et
celle qui a perdu plus de dresde habite
encore d'autres en perdent mais celle
qui a perdu 6,55 en dix ans et trois
fours sont enceintes ans qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour retenir commencer votre
grande comment venu le temps de parole
en ces retards cette commune sur cnn
comment rendre cette commune attractive
je pense que si il ya des habitants qui
sont partis quand vous le dites si cinq
est qu est ce que ça fait un moment j'ai
pas vu un goût posée sous le titre le
basque web pour faire du logement
maintenant je sais je suis en contact
avec certaines rapprochez vous du
microsite athènes personnes de la
commune qui sont partis un peu sur le
loin sous la joue pas et c'est parce
qu'ils m'ont dit il n'ya pas de
logements pour noah va soit on voulait
bien rester sous bassement n'y en a pas
on est obligé d'aller chez le voisin et
en sachant si les habitants portent sur
le sou sur le lien ou la joue par
ailleurs systématiquement donc il vous
faut vous vous préconisez un programme
de logement de réalisation de
constructions leur semble que l'esa
avait dit fallait créer 10 % de
logements sur les communes par milliers
des logements sociaux sociaux maintenant
une mandature de six ans j'ai jamais vu
une grue posée sous le titre le vase
alors au terme de développement
économique est ce qu'il faudrait faire
en quoi le confort du logement ça on est
dans le volet social maintenant
développement économique est ce qu'il
faudrait faire alors pour le
développement économique la chose à
faire c'est dur recensé un petit peu les
choses qui existent sous bassement déjà
menton mais moi je regardais ce qui
existe sous le besoin on sait qu'il ya
des habitations se bat soins il y à des
développements à faire parce que l'état
ne permet de faire certains
développements pour je vais pas dire à
la recrue le à l'antenne mais j'ai des
propositions a proposé aux habitants de
basse pointe pour sortir un petit peu de
ce ce situation qui fait que
systématiquement si on met en place ou
besoin systématiquement ça va apporter
alors qu'est ce qu'on met en place parce
que vous voulez dire ou ne pas dire non
je veux vous le dis oui je dirai oui
mais ces cessions programmées pendant
mon programme que aucun dossier les
dossiers ne sont pas en couture et je
veux dire que je ne peux pas dire ben
ali quelques pas mon programme de façon
voiture que vous est versé à vous piquer
vos idées alors monsieur golvet qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire pour rendre
attractif le territoire de basse pointe
alors c'est une question vaste déjà à la
base effectivement on a parlé d'appel on
a parlé d' apaisement
parce que je pensais pas que
l'apaisement c'est un passage d'une dune
doit tourner d'une gauche apaisement
c'est pour ces pour la population
effectivement il faut de la paisible
population
effectivement alors redonner du sens à
la politique pour moi c'est l'avis de
lui en achetant le groupe aujourd'hui où
je suis président c'est l'humain mettre
au sens de notre politique lune c'est
important c'est très important
m la question est sur les solutions pour
rendre la trame des véhicules siv
activités au jusqu'à elle a perdu de la
population et on a perdu la population
pourquoi on a perdu le logement on n'a
pas de logement à basse-pointe les
logements se fait ailleurs les
aujourd'hui les jeunes gens veulent des
logements nouvelle génération ils ne
trouvent pas basse pointe
ils vont ailleurs j'aurais pu comprendre
qu'un jeune porte sur un pôle attractif
comme le centre où partent en métropole
il ya des jeunes qui sont partis en
métropole qui porte
mais aujourd'hui ce qui me déçoit
profondément c'est que nos jeunes nos
cousins nos amis nos voisins partent
pour aller je n'ai rien contre les
communes de hadda côté 1 ce sont des
amis ce sont des cousins parfois qui
partent à oloron 1 joue pas au macumba
ceux qui vont
or ces des voisines et communes voisines
vont renforcer et aujourd'hui on a
voient là une manne financière le soft
le martinique sur frau ah ben voilà le
mardi 9 au pourquoi on l'a perdu le
match
en fait c'était pour vous ça pouvait
être quelque chose mais bien sûr mais ça
va contribuer à l'attractivité des
pièces du ca les commerçants mais il y
avait une vie avec le martinique sur
faut pour qu'on a perdu parce qu'on a eu
aujourd'hui de jeunes de jeunes
martiniquais qui sont venus porter un
projet et puis aujourd'hui on a une
municipalité maire sortante qui a créé
une régie parallèle ou parfaire oui mais
il faut il faut il faut que les
prétoires le sache aujourd'hui qu'on a
pris on veut faire voir bosser les
jeunes qui était pas bon vous voulez de
l'argent et c'est pas vrai c'est la
collectivité la ville de bath monde qui
a pris et qui a failli mais mettre en
échec cette manifestation la dernière
manifestation et grâce à la 7e
on a pu faire cette manifestation
aujourd'hui voilà et n'existe plus et
c'est une priorité pour nous le groupe
de mettre en place parce que il faut à
propos d'une martinique sur frau ça vous
intéresse
lucien césarine on vous fait parler
parce qu'il faut que vous rattraper un
peu de votre temps de parole
mais enfin bon si vous ne souhaitez pas
parler longtemps non mais je pensais que
les autres non il n'y a pas de souci
pour ça je vais vous répondre oui c'est
quelque chose d'une activité sportive
qui fait que ça valorise ce tu eu tout
ce qui est sportif cela comme une ça
amène un petit peu de personnes
l'extérieur tout bas ce point pour
animer tu veux pas je trouve ça super
intéressant mais ce que je trouvais
dommage dans tout cela c'est nous qu'on
avait des professionnels qui venait des
gens qui était sorti un petit peu dans
le monde entier et se bat ce point et je
trouve ça un peu dommage qu'on n'a pas
pu faire profiter à aux écoles primaire
au collège que nous avons sur le
territoire le bassin de questionner ces
professionnels voire peut-être moins
peut-être une future
professionnel en surf abbas mais j'ai dû
prouver ça parce qu'en fin de compte il
y avait des choses qu'on pouvait faire
qu'ils étaient mieux profiter pendant
ces professionnels étaient sur le
territoire le besoin est dite villa
didon qu'est ce qu'il manque à à la
commune peut être plus attractive alors
l'attractivité je pense que d'abord il
faut pas la pensée uniquement pour
batman mais pour le grand nombre voilà
parce que tu n'es pas isolé et je crois
que pour pouvoir permettre qu'il y ait
un développement aussi bien je prends le
grand georges ces prêcheurs mon euros
j'ajoute pas bouillon basse-pointe
macouba grand-rivière jeu le projet qui
était de faire en sorte que ce soit une
zone rurale de revitalisation répond à
cela permette sur une période de cinq
ans que les infrastructures qui
s'installe privé c'est à dire les
entreprises qu'elles soient exonérés
d'impôts parce qu'à partir du moment
faux pas il faut que nous soyons bien
conscient que dans le système français
ski
détruit un peu l'emploi c'est que celles
et ceux sont des charges
alors faut pas non plus dire que quand
vous avez des employés vous ne respectez
pas non plus vos engagements
donc il était important je pense quand
vous avez des zones qui sont aussi
éloignés et qui sont en perte de
population qui est un désert médical qui
a vieilli semaine population qui
existent en france
sur les quinze mille communes de france
en bénéficient de ce dispositif
labourdette mois lorsque vous de la
manière dont j'attends des propositions
de solutions voilà pour une solution
majeure parce que le peu d'entreprises
que nous avons il faudrait déjà commencé
à leur permettre d'être déjà exonérées
sur une certaine période de taxes
d'accord et il faudrait aussi permettre
que par ce dispositif que d'être des
personnes puissent venir s'installer
vous avez des petits métiers c'est pas
tout le temps mauvais des centres
commerciaux les gens ne passent pas
longtemps à acheter à défaire des
courses dont vous avez des designers
vous avez les espaces verts vous avez
les menuisiers vante souvent quand vous
chercher pour vous ça passerait par de
l'incitation moi je pense d'ailleurs
l'on fait tout à fait moi je pense que
c'est à dire les charges sur pourri
parce qu'en fait les gens ne peuvent pas
en permanence travailler dans une forme
d'égalité ou de marché noir ou deux
aiguilles franche une zone franchement
je pense que c'est important que qu'au
niveau du grand nombre parce qu'on a
toujours été d'ailleurs le coeur puisque
juste une juste une aparté vous voyez
par exemple la gendarmerie de
basse-pointe elle dessert grand-rivière
macouba souhaité macumba est d'ailleurs
le code postal de base soit ben c'est le
code postal des trois communes
souhaitent macouba grand et vire donc ce
qui veut dire que en quelque part notre
désertification de population est liée
au fait parce que ce n'est pas attractif
et économiquement parlant
et puis quand on va habiter ailleurs
alors c'est vrai j'entends bien qu'il
faut construire mais fo parcours celui
où pour construire parce que on a aussi
un gros problème sur la ville de basse
ronde comme beaucoup de communes de la
matinée vous aviez le foncier mais vous
avez surtout l'indivision
enfin quand vous traversez le bout de
bois soit le nom de maison qui est là
qui tombe en ruine enfin et puis ça
c'est pas joli pour la commune pas
seulement la commune ovationnent d'une
manière générale donc il faut aussi
qu'on arrive à régler tous ces problèmes
qui lie à haut niveau des familles pour
que nous puissions avancer parce qu'il
ya une loi en principe qui devrait vous
et moi
tout à fait mais à un autre niveau jeudi
qu' il faut être raisonnable on peut pas
faire des projets non plus on se dit
qu'on va faire des choses et puis après
ça tient pas la route
je pense que on a des difficultés on a
des problèmes dont il faut trouver des
solutions pour permettre que les choses
puissent à nouveau rebondir maltais
laisse quasiment plus d'outils bien me
suis levé je vais répondre et est
rappelé que la ville de basket été très
courageuse parce que avant que la
manifestation se déroule à basse-pointe
les 34 communes de martinique avait été
notamment mon prédécesseur pour le surf
nous avons parfaitement pour répondu à
la tintin rappelle déjà j'ai entendu que
oui par rapport aux écoles alors je me
suis vraiment rappeler que ça a été fait
dans les écoles que ça continue et non
seulement les échos la basse et le
collège de basket mais aussi le collège
le lycée de terville je serai des jeunes
martiniquais de tous les lycées venait
par rapport nous avons mis en place en
accord avec le rectorat
venez pratiquer ce que j'appelle
l'apprentissage des langues notamment le
portugais et je veux dire que cette idée
aussi a été en déclinaison appliquer
aussi à cette marée part par la ville de
sète mal la plupart des communes du nord
atlantique et du nord caraïbes les
collèges on a vu vraiment un vrai défilé
de jeunes de collégiens de lycéens venus
pour parler le portugais l'espagnol et
l'anglais alors vos propositions pour
rendre la commune qu'au plus attractive
et j'avais simplement rappelé que la
ville pour finir sur le surf
on a parlé dans les médias on a fait
tout un barbu foot ou de manigod et que
nous avons alors j'entends parler je
vais même pas relevé de caisse etc
je veux simplement dire que on on quand
on sert de facilitateur à la fois auprès
et je demande de rappeler que le chef a
été à la demande du maire inaction
labellisé cap nau ils vous laissent à
peine deux minutes heure de ton paru et
c'est à dire que nous étions vraiment
engagés dans la croissance bleue 1 par
rapport au surf
on dit que unis n'a été fait mais je
rappelle
le point de sun le port a été rhabillé
habilité à hauteur de 250 mille euros et
que actuellement nous sommes en chantier
j'ai entendu dire qu'à pas de rouge mais
a quand même là l'appel d'offres a été
lancé là pour l'église pour vous 3
millions 7 et que dans le cadre du
logement
nous sommes en train avec cap nau
puisque je rappelle l'importance de la
loi nôtre et dans le cadre de ce qu'on
appelle le pays et la chine ont vingt
noms pour voir l'ensemble des logements
et puis un niveau très important ce
genre mais si on veut parler
d'aménagement du territoire
il y à une donne qui est très important
c'est l'érosion de la falaise et là nous
sommes en train avec des services de
l'état en train de travailler
et dans ces temps de crise on par
rapport à ce problème fondamental pour
lequel le brgm inverse à mon
prédécesseur mais un rapport qui date de
plus de dix ans eh bien nous sommes
entrain de voix et c'est dans ce cadre
là qu'on va pouvoir intégrer les
équipements sportifs notamment le stade
est aussi le logement très bien
l'érosion de la falaise livory filet
l'évoquer mais sérieux qui a fait
allusion
alors je signale qui reste un peu moins
maintenant d'un quart d'heure démission
donc voilà j'ai presque terminé
lucien césarine allez-y vous avez la
parole vous voulez réagir à ce que tout
à fait c'est lorsque lorsque je dis a
pas de réduction etc
c'est la même chose qu'elle avait dit la
veille qu'il avait six minutes en
qu'elle avait l exacte peut-être pas
tout les utiliser les quelques dizaines
seulement à qu'elle avait promis à la
population qu'elle faisait l'église
assez rapidement et qui fait que c'est
de la même chose qu'elle dit qu'il ya
toujours un programme pour faire des
choses et qui fait systématiquement elle
met toujours les habitants en attente de
quelque chose vous pensez que ce que
pensaient que l'arrivée la
réhabilitation de l'église aurait dû
déjà être terminée avant la fin de ce
mandat
après c'est la meilleur de moi là
d'après ce qu'elle avait dit non ses
propres engagements ses propres centres
jeunesse c'est ce que je dois m alors
qui fait que dans la même manière
qu'elle a répondu pour les goûts je me
suis dit faudra que je leur réponds
parce que enfin compte
on peut faire tous des promesses comme
moi aussi je peux faire beaucoup de
promesses mais je ne peux pas tenir une
population
pour dire on va faire je vais faire ne
vous inquiétez pas les choses feu il ya
six ans passés on n'a rien vu la commune
de batz soins en six ans vous n'avez
rien vu j'ai vu moi très bien non mais
c'est votre opinion je moi je vous pose
des questions concernant le
développement agricole puisque vous
dites que vous êtes je crois que ces
photos lui césarine tout à fait qu'est
ce que vous avez comme proposition est
ce que vous avez et commence à élaborer
un programme de ce point de vue là toute
la commune de basse pointe soit le
développement agricole exactement parce
que j'ai des jeunes qui me dit si on
avait un petit bout de terrain
systématiquement poids cultiver ce
terrain
jeudi c'est vrai qu'on a un coût pour
elles le font c'est ce besoin puisque
pratiquement tout l'été avec des tenues
ou pas dans les briquets et qui fait que
systématiquement il faudra qu'on
travaille le nôtre note manière ça donc
on a beaucoup de personnes qui ont dû
terrain vide sous bassins levron un
petit peu comment on peut développer
saaq ces gens là on va voir si on peut
faire des contrats voit avec la safer
voit avec les essences pour voir si on
peut récupérer au passé des contrats
avec les propriétaires pour le faso pour
donner à ces jeunes la porte unités de
exercer le métier d'agriculteur donc
c'est la ville qui
financerait tout ça comment alors
directement commença donc voilà c'est
avec les institutions on va regarder
commençons avec les lois etc car ce qui
existe pour qu'on puisse adapter en
fonction de ça et de basson le médecin
en place de façon pour donner à ces
jeunes là pour ses unités
de fait la culture de banques des terres
réponse de terre qui existe sous
bancarisées voilà en terme de cette
activité on peut aussi parler pan du
tourisme rural également tout à fait
tout à fait parce qu'il ya tout un
circuit je le fais assez souvent
souvent le week-end et a déçu cuche ou
bas suède qui existe qui est magnifique
lorsque vous faites le cradi c'est vous
retombez sur le bouton on est en mode on
vous tombez sous le macumba magnifique
il ya des choses qu'on peut mettre en
place on s'autorise vert et caetera et
qui fait que en plus la martinique s'est
développée au niveau il ya beaucoup de
visiteurs sur la martinique de touristes
etc
on peut mettre en place des choses pour
les faire visiter les l'hérault de base
poindre où les quartiers existants et le
leyritz monsieur relevé qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait aleris et ben il est fermé oui
c'en est fermé mais je voudrais juste
quand même fait un petit mot sur leur
culture pour la lisant même je suis fils
d'agriculteur et moi-même été j'étais co
exploitants avec les parents à la
culture dans mon jeune âge plus jeune
âge
donc ce qu'on doit mettre en place aussi
pour les agriculteurs c'est des sites
des lieux pour pouvoir écouler leurs
marchandises
aujourd'hui la collectivité organise des
manches et sur la devanture du marché
c'est aberrant mais c'est que c'est
comme ça à basse-pointe c'est comme ça
on organise un marché sur la devanture
sur le parking du marché mais pas sur le
marché même avec des agriculteurs
d'autres communes
et on a dix agriculteurs à bagdad on en
a beaucoup et l'inculture passe mais me
dit marc gales s'écriant l'éducation je
passe du coq à l'âne qui sont n'a pas
beaucoup de temps
l'éducation la sécurité de nos enfants
on fait quoi
les écoles et c'est bien beau l'église
je comprends à l'église on doive en
notre église
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour l'éducation il
et les bâtiments vétustes cas sur le
territoire de basket
aujourd'hui on a démoli le bâtiment face
de la mairie en prétextant que le
bâtiment était un danger pour les jeunes
mais les bâtiments où les jeunes même
sont à l'intérieur c'est pas un danger
ces bâtiments sont pas en danger
aujourd'hui pour le sport le stade de
basket mais c'est vrai qu'on allait
évoquer le sort
allez-y le stade de batman je suis un
ancien footballeur aussi j'ai arrêté ça
fait deux ans ben c'est un crève coeur
c'est pou des personnes aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont pratiqué le football à basse
pointe aujourd'hui c'est un crève coeur
de voir le stade dans cet état
aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que puisque
on a entendu sur les ondes que madame le
maire sur la mince entente a dit qu'elle
a dépensé 80 mille euros ou ses 80 mille
euros sont passés parce que les gens les
les les fanatiques de 2,2 de foot le
voyez pas les 80000 euros sur le stade
ayant rien n'a été fait sur le savait
que c'était un dossier prioritaire sac
il le fallait parce que pas peut-être à
un moment on peut pas tout faire en six
ans a quand même un nom mais je dis que
c'est un dossier prioritaire de ses
priorités
ce qui est prioritaire c'est la jeunesse
notre jeunesse de basse pointe et ça
passe par là ces structures là accueille
nos jeunes de basse pointe aujourd'hui
tout ce qui a trait aux à la jeunesse et
priorité à mon sens
entendu didier gaulle vais donc on va
passer a dit vela you do bon
effectivement concernant le
développement agricole et puis peut-être
aussi quelques mots sur le dossier
d'église enfin qu'est le chantier même
faudrait dire parce que madame la maire
a annoncé que ça y est le chantier est
lancé
c'est très bien alors concernant le
domaine agricole c'est vrai que la
majorité des terres sont détenus par des
grands planteurs d'accord mais vous avez
beaucoup de petits planteurs donc il
faut mettre en place des coopératives et
puis la dynamique agricole aussi passe
pas par une biodiversité mais aussi par
des des produits de haut de gamme je
veux dire que si tout le monde commence
à blanc des god lada chine mais y aura
un problème pour et d'écoulement des
produits
donc il faut une entente entre les
agriculteurs et cette entente là aussi
elles passent par ce que vous allez vers
les agriculteurs et vous vous êtes en
capacité de pouvoir leur proposer une
organisation de la production agricole
alors pour ça c'est aussi un travail de
terrain de proximité
vous ne pouvez pas alors et c'est vrai
et c'est dommage quand des agriculteurs
de d'autres communes qui viennent vendre
leurs produits
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on est en
compétition avec les gens mais d'autres
personnes ils comprennent pas pourquoi
eux qui ont produit parce que le travail
de la terre c'est quelque chose qui est
très dur mes parents mon père était issu
du monde agricole même donc mal jeudi
après le jeudi à l'époque quand j'étais
en classe n'est pas le mercredi jallet
récolte est vendue au monde à
l'intercommunalité de temps en temps ça
oui oui non mais sans sinon ce oui mais
quand vous êtes dans une période de
fêtes et que vous avez envie de re d'un
petit peu plus vous êtes dans un peu
dans une région économiquement justement
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'autres activités
c'est toujours un plus mais c'est un
choix moi je respecte le choix des gens
après les gens vont expliquer leur choix
mais il faut assumer aussi cette cette
incompréhension de la part des
agriculteurs de basse preuves concernant
l'église l'église c'est un très très
gros dossier
cette église est là c'est pas en 2014
qu'elle s'est détériorée elle a commencé
des terriers en 2005 2007 à la borie a
eu un tremblement de terre il ya eu le
il ya d'abord eu un cyclone et puis
ensuite ce qui a vraiment failli lisez
le bâtiment ça a été le tremblement de
terre
aujourd'hui c'est tellement dégradée
vous allez être forcément dans un
investissement qui très lourd
il faut faire très attention dans les
engagements que l'on prend je comprends
parfaitement que peut-être à 2014 on
était persuadé on en a fait un élément
de campagne tant mieux il n'y a pas il
n'y a pas que les catholiques cela sur
autre chose sur la commune de batman
vous avez d'autres confessions
religieuses
ceci étant dit les grandes personnes qui
la plupart d'entre elles ont été
baptisées dans cette église l on vit l
on vit voilà pourquoi de kelt elles vont
quitter ce monde d'avoir un lieu
magnifique pour pouvoir s'en aller ça il
faut respecter cela et il faut faire en
sorte mais j'aimerais que ce que
plusieurs mois j aimerais si toutefois
je suis élu qu'on puisse avancer sur ce
dossier qui soit bouclé une fois pour
toutes en six ans alors je sais pas
comment on va faire
voilà parce qu'il faut d'abord savoir
quel est l'état des finances de la
commune quand on va arriver aux
commandes le 15 le 15 mars
parce que vous n'allez pas non plus
annoncé aux gens que vous allez faire
plein de choses et puis les caisses sont
vides
donc c'est très important de savoir
exactement quelle est la capacité
d'investissement de cette commune pour
pouvoir se lancer dans des projets mais
je pense que d'abord si on arrive à
faire le mieux vivre ensemble
on aura déjà gagné merci beaucoup voilà
tout on arrive au terme de ce débat
alain donc on va passer à la fin et
auront une conclusion par par candidat
et nous allons au mans je crois que on a
peut-être encore un petit peu de temps
pour lucien césarine qui est vraiment
trade
alors je vous lis réagir alors peut-être
pas les trois minutes parce que nous
sommes aussi contraints par le temps de
faire le tri dans thales vous voulez
donc à lise vous pouvez parler encore
une minute et puis à l'introduire à
l'affairé conclusion je voulais venez
sur le stade comme monsieur gold disait
j'ai entendu bien à méré ce une antenne
qui disait qu'elle a mis 80 mille euros
sur le stade entretien etc
lorsqu'on voit on va au stade on peut
pas remonter aux tribunes on peut pas
monter ce trader pourquoi parce que
c'est fermé ya pas de sécurité et c'est
un début cc il ya plus petits sécurité
sous ce gradé lorsque vous allez sourd
au niveau du grillage
enfin compte faut mettre des minettes
parce que sinon lorsque le ballon tombe
sous se dégagera vous risquez d'avant
les éclaboussures de la roue et c'est
parce que vraiment si vous appuyez
profond aussi les gens sont pas en
sécurité
d'accord donc c'est vétuste et délabré
que ça c'est pas du tout alors les 80000
euros je me suis demandé où sont passés
bon ben maintenant écoutez je pense
qu'on aura un autre débat besson non
mais qu'est-ce interpellé vous la
regardez pas mais on sent bien que vous
avez envie alors non madame quasi mairie
voilà monsieur non mais j'ai dit ben
sedrine vous interpelle sur 120 mille
euros de ca 4 400 ce sont des travaux
qui fallait faire de toute urgence
parce qu'en plus avec le rectorat nous
l'avons partenariat parce que les jeunes
du collège et les jeunes de dix écoles
primaires viennent pratiquer d'éducation
physique et sportive sur le stade dont
nous avons mis tout en oeuvre pour les
des garanties sécuritaires soient bien
respectées alors moi j'avais bien joué
on ne voit pas parce qu'on est
certainement dans et je ne vois vraiment
pas pour quelle raison on allait
inventer un certain nombre de choses
parce que x ou y avait énormément tabou
ce stade donc je n'ai connu j'ai
pratiqué le ps quand je suis revenu
avant dit nik j'ai trouvé les stades
dans le même état donc moi j'aime bien
bon tout relève du maire mais en fait
confiance à l'état délabré en misant
moser c'est ça le délabrement était le
respect que je vous vous arrêtez cela
sienne
et ils ont reconnu des personnes qui ont
la pratique du sport
on connaît ce qu'effectivement c'était
état de dégradation n'est pas imputable
en fait j'aime bien gérée $ offert son
côté baba les deux je croise pas
vraiment dit encore marié vue et à lui
le désamiantage
il ya eu la descente des cloches il ya
eu la dépose des hôtels là nous sommes
en train de travailler sur la dépose du
maître-autel quand on me dit qu'on a
qu'on avait vu très dur non nous allons
études spatiales conclusions au tirage
au sort si vous qui commencez mesdames
casini a eu ce n'est jamais que vous
comprendre que j'ai terminé ben moi j'ai
compris que commenciez on m'a dit henri
gicl en plus vous débordez donc bon vous
allez terminer alors allez-y ballon mais
c'est une conclusion qui est vraiment
courtin c'est à dire une minute maximum
c'est vraiment avancer votre pays vous
adresser aux auditeurs et lecteurs
voilà à toi les prétoires 013 jeudi que
voilà si je me porte garant sur la
commune de basse-pointe c'est parce que
je me suis organisée de façon à être
disponible pour la population et comme
je dis ensemble basse pointe et nous
ferons les choses ensemble
voilà merci monsieur golvet votre
conclusion
alors ma conclusion est simple
aujourd'hui il faut être réactif faut
que les points toiser les pointois les
pointoise et les pointois soirée hâtif
ne pas laisser les gens encore une fois
les couilles au nez avec des promesses
non tenues et n'a beaucoup on va bon il
faut plus que dix minutes une heure
d'émission pour en parler aujourd'hui si
aujourd'hui à 41 ans je viens en tant
que tête de liste c'est parce que j'ai
réellement envie de faire quelque chose
pour la ville de basse pointe pour les
poulets pointoise et les pointois parce
que je pense que aujourd'hui c'est
légitime que nous en tant que point toi
on est tous les quatre tours de la table
on a envie de faire des choses bien pour
notre ville est aujourd'hui c'est c'est
le souhait ce le souhait de liyannaj
pointois et c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
la dite ville à lyon alors c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui je pensais la
reconstruction
voilà donc il ya une église ni à un
stade il ya des infrastructures
scolaires
il y à aussi on oublie j'espère que les
entreprises vont pouvoir travailler en
ce sens pour cette reconstruction que
aussi la population pour toutes ces
maisons qui sont en indivision
ne serait ce que dans le bourg moi mon
programme c'est la reconstruction ça
c'est une première chose la deuxième je
crois que il faut aussi faire défaut
mais ce qu'on est capable de tenir et la
population est capable d'entendre ça
n'allait pas promettre la lune alors que
vous n'avez même pas la possibilité de
sortir de basculer à fort de france
donc il faut être réaliste il faut faire
une campagne participative et écouter
écouter écouter les gens être proche
d'eux alors on me reproche de ne pas
être souvent sur ba soit ce qui est
d'ailleurs il faut parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent puis
qu'hydro mais qui ne dorment pas dans la
commune m'enfin bon je ne suis pas là
pour épiloguer sur la vie de tout un
chacun en tous les cas l'avs
l'engagement politique c'est quelque
chose d'énorme
il faut pouvoir tenir six ans en tous
les cas je demande aux personnes qui
nous écoutent ans jusqu'à de voter de
faire voter pour mme alice voilà merci
beaucoup à tous d auditionner 10 soit
être terminée marie-thérèse casimir yeux
bien évidemment je demande aux pontois
la possibilité je crois comme on a eu
cette surprise 2014
je sais qu'à à 19 dont vous avez même
pas 30 secondes à l'isie 2004 à 11 mars
2010 9 mars et les alliances malsaines
et en mars de m'élever nous allons
continuer à faire le travail que nous
avons commencé notamment l'église la
réhabilitation de l'église et plus le
complexe scolaire
j'écoute beaucoup de gens n'a pas parlé
enfin le dossier très très bien avancé
mais en aucun cas je dis qu'on ne peut
pas nous demander un dynamique maîtresse
de faire sa vie n'a pas été fait en dix
neuf ans voilà merci mesdames et
messieurs d'avoir participé à ce débat à
ce débat qui était d'une bonne tenue
merci alain ivory de l'avoir donc animé
également avec moi merci merci à
claudine était le biel qui était à la
réalisation
désir qui kelly qui a présidé à toute
l'installation technique voilà c'est
notre responsable technique en radio on
le remercie aussi infiniment et puis à
toute l'équipe
la rédactrice en chef frédéric mas
seront là de voix de brigitte bron voilà
et jean-marc partie
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée la
politique continue sur notre antenne
toute la semaine et le prochain débat ce
sera vendredi avec la commune du carbet
et oui voilà
bonne soirée à vous tous premières
élections municipales le débat
[Musique]